i think that we need to talk about
whether or not
chris cuomo uh is a is italian as well
very very is he italian
have you heard this story guys yes yep
chris cuomo
had a boss
and you have to respect this right yep
his boss at abc news
uh on her like retirement party yeah
walks up to her
grabs her ass allegedly squeezes it
allegedly one hand one bear hug slides
one hand down to a buttock you need a
little singular and
says
i can do this now that you're no longer
my boss and it's not alleged he admitted
to it
he admitted to this yeah remove those
allegiance
miles
okay
this interesting this
is a sexual harassment or is this
italian culture
it's italian culture i mean that's what
his dad said
well that's my brother
his oh yeah his brother yeah yeah yeah
so he's daddy but it's a different yeah
yeah
he's dead he's daddy he's daddy yeah but
the fact that fredo had the [ __ ]
foots but to go up to a woman that was
his boss not in his boss anymore not he
boss it not boss anymore he was i said
was he a former boss yeah it was right
past tense it was his boss and then grab
cheek and then squeeze cheek and say
that little line
and then later email her apologizing
about it disgusting
in front of her husband her husband is
there oh and her husband's husband is
right there and what did he do though
nothing [ __ ]
dude what a [ __ ] [ __ ] you gotta punch
take him on a boat foreign for real it
seems like he denied touching anyone
inappropriately
what do you mean so then why would he
apologize yeah
i apologize for quote in a way that
acting in a way that made people feel
uncomfortable and what would that be not
an embrace you're allowed to hug people
that you know maybe it was grabbing a
girl's butt cheek and separating her
[ __ ] lips
from the back wow
dude maybe that's what it was yeah maybe
he was grabbing those cheeks and doing a
little kermit mouth
okay maybe that's what it was ace
ventura yeah
detective yeah
yeah he was it was a little bit
disrespectful
this [ __ ] guy can i be honest with
you i think he i don't see what the big
it was 16 years ago
whoa
akash sings god takes no okay go for it
16 years ago not that what he did is
okay but he apologized it was 16 years
ago and it's the only incident we know
of so he did some [ __ ] that was wrong he
said sorry and then she said something
like when he saw that he was helping his
brother this she says i'm like this is
how he operates and it's like it's one
allegation there's no pattern with one
allegation way before me too
2017 2018 we should have known it was
wrong in 2005 but i think me too for
everybody was like oh
we we've been we've all done some [ __ ]
now that's over the line for sure but he
apologized the next day did you read his
full apology it's a real awkward apology
so funny it's a real awkward episode
right before you read that and i do want
to hear this i think that that is a very
objective and nuanced approach to this
story that's so it's not okay that he
did it but he apologized the next day no
scandal made him apologize wasn't a fake
thing now the apology mark's about to
read is [ __ ] awkward that's good but
it's an apology and i think we've all
[ __ ] up something then realized the
gravity of our error and then stumbled
through an apology because we realized
how much we [ __ ] up um that's a good
point and so he sent an email the next
day that says
uh
now that i think of it dot dot dot i'm
ashamed that's the the header of the
email yep
though my hearty greeting was a function
of being glad to see you dot dot dot
yeah christian slater got arrested for a
kind of similar act
though born of an of an alleged negative
intent unlike my own and as a husband i
can empathize with not liking to see my
wife patted as such so pass along my
apology to your very good and noble
husband and i apologize to you as well
for even putting you in such a position
next time i will remember the lesson no
matter how happy i am to see you
this guy's a scumbag
this guy's an absolute [ __ ] monster
apology he goes he's a rapist bro all
right
the guy's a rapist
allegedly hit it
did he not rape her butt
did he not he said he said he patted
yeah he said uh yeah to see my wife
patted it one man's pat is another man's
grope
you don't know what a pat is she stopped
him in the moment too in the moment she
was he was she said he said i can do
that now and she pushed him when i was
like no no you can't i have a husband
yeah so you guys got to stop patting my
ass every time i walk by bro now you're
getting gross
they're sliding a finger in next time
like in basketball you make a shot you
get the pat on the ass like i try to
stick i try i have a policy here yeah at
schultz studios what's that
your body fact check this my choice
and that's just how things go is that
what hr says
that's it that's the policy all right
dick has been touched by me
okay
your ass has been touched by me yeah and
mark mark has put a finger inside of
your ass
yeah yeah okay that was direct orders i
didn't even want to do it he has damn
near threatened to suck everybody's dick
in here yeah that's true on a regular
basis on a regular basis i promised
really
that's a promise i still might take it
up on that one
that's what i'm talking about and you've
removed your clothing i have taken off
my clothing during an important very
important conversation
calls and i've jerked off okay i don't
remember wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait i jerked
off
wait wait i jerked off on all of you
i every one of you i've jerked off other
than the jellyfish incident when did you
jerk off on me you guys didn't know this
but nope
nope there was there was a time
where we were having the group exercise
when we were doing the bonding the group
bonding exercises nope don't remember we
were sitting back to back in a circle
everybody's back's in a circle i missed
that day and
i told you
that
i was gonna jerk off
that definitely wasn't here that day was
it that day you were here did you say
jerk off or did you use another it was
during our hr conference yeah
team building i started masturbating
i started masturbating and
i i jerked off into the air and i was
very someone else was also jerking oh i
do remember this someone else looked at
me you said turtle time yes i did yeah i
did say i said turtle time
i jerked off and i thought i would be
the only one
someone else was jerking off and i got
hit too
i don't know who it was [ __ ] shots
over here bro say what schultzy ck
hey listen listen listen listen we all
got to get in where we fit in but
somebody else
somebody else was doing it bro no
i don't know who's the
was it culprit was it you was it you was
it you
was it miles was it shifty
miles had been backed up for a long time
i jerk off to you guys in the privacy of
my own home oh well thank you
respect thank you i appreciate that
really respect only what else would i
think about you ever jerking off and
then like you have you have to like
think about like work or something that
comes into your head you're like oh yeah
get out of here you guys do that me
neither
[Laughter]
now have you ever been hitting it no
since someone will call you like right
at the moment and you're like [ __ ]
shifty then you gotta hang up but you're
thinking about him right isn't like you
know nothing
yeah yeah actually this is a really fun
game to like say things that have
happened and they just go now yeah
[Laughter]
never happened to me i was curious
um al go yeah i got one that was never
jerked though yeah i don't know i'll be
honest with you guys i was joking about
the jerk-off thing yeah same same thing
i've never been jerked off by you guys
or uh or you guys never jerked off on me
and i've never jerked off on you and we
actually never had that bonding
experience oh okay i made up that story
damn
i thought you were a credible journalist
bro
yeah [ __ ] i was lying for headlines dude
i was lying for clickbait you're trying
to be inflammatory i was literally
trying to be inflammatory because i
thought that it would like drive views
or something to the pod you know what i
mean but like i i'm
i don't want to do that cheap [ __ ] dude
yeah
i don't want to do that you're going to
drug off dude for real yeah yeah if i'm
going to take some time out of my day to
pleasure myself then i'm just going to
do that very honorable of you yeah i'm
an honorable guy that's why you're
wearing your hunting jacket
what do you think i'm hunting in this
[ __ ] girls with shaved side of their
heads
the headline is hilarious what's
headline because the headline is
literally uh
chris cuomo sexually harassed me but i
don't think he should be fired
respect well she wants him to apologize
on air well i hope he'll use his power
to make change yeah
you